le suffrage par le sort et de la nature
de la démocratie écrivait montesquieu
dans l'esprit des lois au 18e trois
siècles plus tard le maire de maurepas
grégory gars ici a choisi le tirage au
sort pour former son conseil des aînés
une institution participatif pour les
morts pas un de plus de 62 ans
je veux aussi continuer de travailler
ses liens forts que j'ai avec les
mauraciens en les associant évidemment
aux décisions et en recueillant aussi
leur avis évidemment les élus reste
décisionnaire je suis le représentant
donc j'ai dû continuer de décider mais
je construis avec les moyens et c'est
pour ça que je multiplie les instances
participatives composé de 46 membres 30
titulaire et 16 suppléant
le conseil des aînés est chargé
d'éclairer le ccas trois commissions
thématiques cadre de vie prévention et
lien social des sujets de réflexion
allant de la mobilité à la santé en
passant par le maintien à domicile ou
les loisirs c'est pour pouvoir
participer un petit peu l'amélioration
du cadre de vie de ma ville
les personnes âgées il ya aussi de plus
en plus de personnes handicapées donc a
besoin aussi de prévoir beaucoup
d'activités non seulement des activités
mais des prises en charge au niveau des
aides à domicile au niveau des droits de
connaître les droits
je me suis dit peut-être que au niveau
de la mairie il y aurait peut-être la
possibilité de faire quelque chose par
rapport aux personnes qui sont à
mobilité réduite handicapés comme moi
qui reste domicile prochain rendez vous
la commission lien social prévu fin juin
début juillet à l'ordre du jour
l'élection des coordinateurs de la
commission et les discussions sur le
voyage seniors 2018